why did profiles and poise start up and
why haven't i done one in quite some
time
it's a good question let's dive into it
shall we drex here from drexfactorpoi
sharing with you the love of poi
spinning and flow arts to benefit your
body and brain and today
i wanted to talk about a feature that
i've had on my channel that i may have
again someday
but why it kind of fell into disuse
before we dive in i just want to give a
quick shout out to the friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroterra light toys spin balls
and ultra poi for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these amazing
businesses and what they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that i've got
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to non-business
friends of the channel johnny howard les
machinski and becca beckham thank you
all so very much for your support from
my work and my mission
so the coveted numbers from montgomery
county in maryland where i live
have dropped dramatically in the past
couple weeks so i'm going to take this
as an opportunity to go for a little bit
of a walk sam's mask and chat with you
all about this yeah so profiles and poi
for a long time it was one of if not the
most popular feature that i had on my
youtube channel
it featured interviews with people that
had had a big impact on the world of poi
talking about the history of their
careers major inflection points in them
and the choices that they made at those
different inflection points and why
and i haven't done one of those
interviews in quite some time
i kind of wanted to talk about why that
was
so like originally
profiles and poi kind of happened on a
lark
the first profiles employee interview
was with my friend keith marshall who
was touring through the united states
back and i think it was 2013.
um
so
like most people uh my introduction to
keith was through his video and to phone
which another friend mcp shot of him
and uh
it was kind of fascinating meeting him
because from his video i assumed that he
was going to be this
really really kind of rough and burly
biker type you know he had those big
long red dreads and
he always seemed to be wearing a scowl
whenever you saw him in a video and much
to my surprise keith turned out to be
one of the sweetest human beings that i
have ever met in my life
um he and i got to be really really
close friends he came and stayed with me
for a little while in dc
and we got to know each other really
really well um i'd venture to say
probably we got to know each other
better than most people in the flow arts
have ever gotten to know either one of
us individually
and
there was a part of me that kind of
wanted to like show people this other
side of keith you know
not the like you know
big burly biker type with the scowl on
his face
but this really really sweet dude who
had this like adorably high squeaky
voice
and had really really thoughtful things
to say about how we practice and why he
does the things that he does so at flame
festival that year i sat down and i
interviewed him
um and you know just because i was doing
it at the time my friend teddy petrovsky
was also at flame and i sat down and
talked to him too
and so those two interviews became
the first of what turned out to be a
series that i did for several years to
come afterwards
um mainly it came
about because once i had told keith's
story and
shared with the broader world
what an interesting person he turned out
to be
i realized there were a lot of other
interesting stories to be told out there
and especially because we are
notoriously a subculture that is
terrible about writing down our history
i thought that this could serve a useful
purpose in you know kind of
laying down the who's and what's in
where's of how this art came to be so
for years after that as i was touring
through the festival circuit whenever i
ran into somebody that i thought was
going to have a really good story i try
and sit down and talk with them and
the results sometimes were mixed
sometimes that conversation would be
hours long
you know zan moore alien john nick
woolsey all of them i sat with for such
a long time it became really really
difficult to edit down their interviews
at a certain point
others like kate mccoy and chris kelly
i actually had a really really difficult
time getting them to talk about
themselves for a variety of different
reasons
those interviews didn't last nearly as
long and in every single case the core
question for me was who has an
interesting story to tell
you know alien john basically jumped
from creating some of the most
foundational tech poi frameworks that we
all still use to this day
to selling fiber whips or you know
talking with zan moore who made a very
very clear choice about when he was
going to disengage with the poi world
that still to this day kind of blows my
mind and of course i also wanted to tell
the story that was the foundations of
poi as we noted in a modern context
and then as i put those videos out
i started to notice something in the
responses to them
that made me a little uncomfortable so
like in my mind when i sat down to talk
with somebody again it was because i
thought that they had an interesting
story to tell
but a lot of people that were watching
those videos kind of thought of it as
like this is the moment where this
person arrives regardless of the fact
that many of these people had careers
that were years or even a decade longer
than my own
and it became a thing
that
people started making demands of who i
would interview now here's one thing
that's incredibly important to recognize
about each and every one of those
interviews
the only way that they were able to
happen is if i ran into the person
physically at an event
you know our paths would have to cross i
would ask them hey can i have like an
hour of your time to sit down and
interview you and you know we can
then get
several minutes worth of b-roll for me
to edit over it and everything
and
you know there have been plenty of
people that i have asked to do that over
the years that just didn't have the time
available
one of my big regrets of course is that
i tried and didn't manage to get john
alvarez to sit down with me for an
interview the last fire drums that i saw
him at
you know likewise
i'd love to do liz knights at some point
but we haven't
been able to have our paths cross at
such a time or such a place where she
has the mental or physical spoons to do
that and so when people started making
demands all of a sudden it started to
feel a little uncomfortable because
not only was it you know
i was doing the best i could in terms of
the physical availability of both me and
the people i was trying to talk to
but also there was another disturbing
pattern that was kind of emerging from
it namely i couldn't help but notice
that a lot of the people that were
demanding more interviews
were demanding interviews with people
that were their friends or they
themselves like in their minds
they were waiting for me to come around
and interview them
which like
that is completely not the purpose of
that series like literally all of those
interviews exist because i thought
somebody had a really cool story to tell
not because it was about saying hey
you've arrived and now you're important
it was about having there be a teachable
moment in all of those interviews it was
about
having there be moments where people
could listen to what these people had to
say and take that as inspiration into
their own lives were many of the people
that i interviewed really important to
the history of poi absolutely
but you know what that was never the
point to me the point to me was always
what inspiration can other people take
in terms of how they structure their
career and their choices with the prop
you know there were several people that
i interviewed that are not considered
super famous to this day
and the reason they got interviewed was
just i thought they had an interesting
story so when people started demanding
specific interviews and more to the
point where they made it clear that they
were waiting for their chance to be
interviewed
that kind of killed a lot of my
enthusiasm for the project because it
just felt like people had missed the
point
they were waiting for their chance to
speak instead of taking an opportunity
to listen
and that really sucked now that is not
to say that i will never do another
profiles employee interview um i'm sure
that i will and i definitely have a list
in my head of people that i would like
to talk to off the top of my head you
know getting liz nice to sit down for an
interview um getting ronin mclaughlin
excuse me mclaughlin i keep
mispronouncing that yuta imamura ivan
mel gorbanov or uh and i always
mispronounced her name uh lara yo from
uh from russia would also be really fun
to interview
um
yeah
but at the same time it's not a thing
that i'm kind of going out of my way to
do right now and also if i'm gonna be
real with you i think that like for the
most part i did a pretty good job of
documenting how we got to where we are
in the poi world right now
you know there's a reason that i haven't
interviewed a lot of the up and comers
in the past few years and it's because
we're still kind of operating within the
paradigm that was created by the
generation of tech spinners that more or
less came of age between 2013 and 2015.
you know i got a lot of the classics in
there i'm still really proud of the fact
that i got to interview both zan moore
and nick woolsey in the span of a year
but in terms of where poi is at right
now you know so much of
the scene right now is still a byproduct
of what it was back then
i don't think there's been a huge amount
of innovation
or people that have taken their careers
in new and exciting directions since
then so
it kind of seems like the documentation
that i did back then is still kind of
the paradigm that we're into this day
although ironically enough
there is actually a lost profiles in poi
interview there's one
that never got posted and uh
it's actually tim goddard interviewing
me
um which i just didn't trust myself to
edit my own story
and at one point teddy petrovsky was
going to to edit it for me but just kind
of fell through
so
yeah
there is actually a missing interview
but i don't think it's the most
important one by any means now i do just
want to throw in one bit of quick
clarification before anybody comes into
my comments section on this stuff
is this me saying that there are not
interesting stories out there in the poi
world right now
absolutely not i am sure that there are
um in fact i think that probably this
period of poi history is going to be a
particularly fruitful one for talking
about how people have adapted to rapid
changes
you know i think that uh the
introduction of tick-tock and the ways
both in which vertical content formats
as well as content discovery algorithms
rather than following individual artists
is going to result in a whole bunch of
interesting changes to the flow arts
worlds but i also think we're in the
early days of that and that it's
probably going to take another couple
years for us to really sort out what the
impact of that has been on the scene
and also it has to be said in full
honesty like i am definitely i don't i
definitely don't have the same kind of
visibility on the scene that i did back
in say 2013 i've been i've been a bit of
a homebody these past few years
for obvious reasons but in the meantime
if you're one of the old heads who's
waiting on new profiles and poi
interviews
i cannot tell you when that might happen
um
i would have to travel in order to do
such a thing and i'm kind of averse to
that right now
but never say never and if you're one of
the newer followers of my channel that
have no idea what profiles and poi is i
will go ahead and link to the playlist
of profiles and poi interviews so you
can go discover them and learn a bit of
poi history from the people that created
it i think like the biggest thing that i
want to get across here is just you know
i started doing those interviews because
i found people that i thought had really
interesting stories to tell and i wanted
to inspire other people with them
so
yeah
i think that if you're looking for
recognition if you're looking to feel
important
looking to feel as though you've arrived
in the poi scene
look for other ways to do that than
getting me to sit down and interview you
because
it's not just that that's a big drain on
the time of the people that i sit down
and talk to it's also a big drain on my
time those interviews take forever to
edit
so i want to make sure that it is
in service of telling a story that i'm
really passionate about too you know
[Music]
hey did you get anything out of this
video if so please make sure to leave a
like comment share and subscribe to help
other people find it and help my channel
grow this video would not be a possible
word not for the kind support of all of
these lovely people right here these are
my flow patrons over on patreon and they
along with the people listed down in the
description help to make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
thank you one and all for your support
if you out there watching are not
currently a supporter and you'd like to
become one you can do so by heading on
over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up you can do
that at the link down in the description
or the card that just popped up if
you're watching this video on youtube
um there you can get access to a whole
host of awesome rewards and even better
you'll be helping me out and supporting
me in my mission to bring poi spinning
and flow arts to the wider world and
helping people connect with their brains
and their bodies as creative individuals
so go check that out please and thank
you thank you for joining me for this
little walk and talk session
i will go ahead and include a link to a
playlist of other vlogs that i have done
on topics such as this one
playlist down in the description as well
as up on screen if you're watching on
youtube uh the youtube algorithm also
thinks you'll like this top video here
so you might want to check that out as
well
make sure to get out and flow today and
i will see you with a new video on
wednesday
peace